hello reject nation how you doing Greg
Alba here John we are going to watch
today a patron video requests one of our
war tears on patreon is whatever video
you requested was definitely put on the
youtubes and speaking of YouTube Andrew
Hayes has a video request for us today
he loves WatchMojo and today he is
requested let's see top 10 scenes that
almost ruined good movies I am praying
that there's no Shawshank Redemption on
here because I it's the one movie I've
successfully not had spoiled for me all
these years
well hey that could all change they can
all change Andrew Hayes you guys should
check out this guy's movie review
channel he has a great great movie
review channel there's a link in the
description box for pin comment as well
reason why it's more than the fact that
he's a patron I've actually sat through
and listening to a bunch of his reviews
this guy really knows his films with
love doing Google Hangouts with the guy
he is 6 foot 4 despite what he might
tell you he is a tall buff beautiful
looking brown gentleman that's a hundred
percent accurate 100% we don't lie here
at the real rejects ever anything here
we go why do they have to do that
welcome to watchmojo.com and today we're
counting down our picks for the top 10
scenes that almost ruined good movies
that was not the only thing I don't
subscribe for more great content for
this list we'll be looking at those
scenes which were so badly terrible and
they almost rude and otherwise fine
movie it's videos tradition a couple
weeks ago acting laughably bad plot
decision bad special effects or
disappointing character deaths on
others number 10 the Mandarin reveal
Iron Man 3 and abate able really for our
men 3 may not have being the greatest
superhero movie of all time but it was
still solid entertainment Robert Downey
jr. was his typical charismatic self the
special effects were fantastic and the
Mandarin was menacing badass and rather
unique until he wasn't the Mandarin has
arguably iron man's greatest enemy was
first portrayed as a terrifyingly
psychopathic man complete with an
intimidating voice and a threatening
demeanor and then we find out he's just
a goofy bumbling idiot and a washed-up
drunk of an actor yeah great saying make
matters worse Killian ends up being the
big bad and he's as cliche as they come
[Music]
number 9 bond deserves a tidal wave by
another day I don't like this movie in
general Rosamund Pike's in this movie
another day was certainly no masterpiece
but it was a fairly enjoyable and can't
be wrong and then there's this scene
which sees bond surfing a massive tidal
wave which is the result of an orbital
satellite shooting solar energy at a
bargain price we can hardly say that
without laughing yeah barely remaining
for 2002 the CGI was lacking a series
known for his practical stunt work was
now resorting to CGI and it all but
ruined the series
number eight cgi Philibert leap or
whatever just a little bit different I
also the Fed this eight this might have
cheesy it looks yeah it's so corny
yeah conscience seen as a freeway chase
can also contain whatever this is the
original matrix was renowned for its mix
of practical and special effects as it
managed to seamlessly blend the two into
movie magic and then there's the burly
brawl which looks like it was ripped
straight from a bad video game no we're
pretty sure even bad video games look
better than this in 2003 the scene is
good premise but it's totally ruined by
the bad CGI bowling pin sound effects
and obvious stunt doubles we'll just
chalk it up to a glitch in the matrix
number seven baked baby
American sniper I see you why do you
hear this I didn't even miss us in the
theaters I didn't notice a big baby
cause so much laughter during the scene
where Chris Kyle holds his baby and the
house is nursery yours couldn't help but
notice that the baby looked particularly
fake and ridiculous the prop baby was so
painfully obvious that it immediately
took audience member and never noticed
it was together online to poke fun at
the doll and the scene the fake baby was
a huge misstep for such a dramatic and
important scene and it almost turned the
war drama into an unintentional comedy
we expect the whole movie yeah it's like
a big deal with that dancing baby number
6
I don't know give me I'll give you guys
this one this if I couldn't couldn't
even get a practical effect Darth Vader
so why did you have to go and do that
this final installment of the prequel
trilogy was easily the best of the three
providing audiences with both grilles
and poignancy yes it was tragic to see
Anakin turned to the dark side and his
burning in the lava was erm a tragic
forever his awakening the fader suit
should have been iconic but then he's
extremely corny yellow anguish ruined
the mood no first we were waiting
decades for this moment and this really
tarnished the experience
[Music]
number five the goofy just screams corny
subtlety went out the window and what we
were left with was more cheese than
anyone should subtlety did you water
he's still crying Oh number four Bane's
dead The Dark Knight Rises
together though
well the Dark Knight Rises may not have
lived up to the wild expectations set by
its predecessor it was still a fun
journey in no small part thanks to Tom
Hardy's brutal and terrifying
performances Bane uTest Batman both
physically and mentally and seriously
he's a villain voice since finger and
then he's okay maybe no but it was still
bad right his brain is about to shoot
Batman Catwoman enters the scene and
blasts the villain away with the bat
pods cannons what a disappointment way
to say goodbye I'm not sure I feel as
strongly about it is you do number three
yellow face yes yup I actually watched
this movie for the first time not long
ago and every time it comes out rough
cuz the only bad part of the movie
unfortunately yes story his supreme lair
and black base in movies and television
case in point
breakfast at tiffany's which contains
one of the most racist characters you'll
ever see Mickey Rooney portrays iy uni
ocean
complete with goofy buckteeth glasses
and a horribly stereotypical Asian
accent seriously it is one of the most
racist things ever
it's just so ridiculous suppose it was a
different time in Hollywood but watching
it today the character is a painfully
damaging blemish on an otherwise
fantastic piece of felt
[Music]
number 2 rewinding time sure Superman
may feel somewhat dated today it is
nevertheless a classic some Earth's
great super huh the famous or perhaps
infamous scene in which Superman turns
back time seriously hurts the film while
it may look impressive
he feels both lazy and confusing is it
just a visual cue for the audience or is
Superman literally spinning the earth
backwards if he is how exactly does that
turn back time it makes no sense yes we
understand that this is a movie about a
flying humanoid alien but it still needs
to adhere to the rules of our planet hi
I'm the hunter I think it's dead before
being veil our top pick here are a few
dishonorable mentions
I forgot this
no completely disagree with that I
really like that sing I don't care what
anyone says pin backer sunshine oh how
do you rule your activist it is a great
in ambitious science fiction okay that
guy discovers pin backer a horrific we
burned and disfigured psychopath and the
movie he'll turns into horror territory
as he stalks and kills the crew
okay - but it comes pretty damn close
sporty loose check out these other great
clips from watching mojo and subscribe
for new videos every day that's a fairly
good list that's it's a fairly good list
about some of these John know some of
these I'm like I don't know if these
qualify is like a scene you know I was
like there's a whole contest I got a
second half of this like with the bane
part is a scene you know is a moment but
the Mandarin reveal in Iron Man 3 yeah
it's not the scene where they reveal him
it's the fact that they revealed that
he's this actor guy that you're taking
with I could argue with this being on
the list more than their number one pick
they arguably only focus on it for one
scene and that scene was so
controversial and I think when you take
some space away from it that our viewers
like myself appreciate that choice John
was with me the time we saw this for the
first time and I hated that it was up on
a second viewing like a year later on
like you know pretty clever I actually
liked that moment from the first time I
see I partly partly because it I just
was not expecting it and for you know
the third Iron Man movie I was like oh
cool like a big surprise but that was
also one of those things that I could
never begrudge somebody being mad about
die another day I think has way more
laws than this scene rented I can't
remember most of the movies drinking a
lot of that from the road I just
remember the first 10 minutes being
annoying as hell but looking back at
this bond surfs tidal wave scene Wow
does that look awful yeah yeah really
awful I thought it was this whole movie
in total that caused this movie to be
rebooted I don't think you move one
scene that made you go ice we got to
start all over again we've been off for
the big fight Whitney oversees all the
agent Smith's that's like a almost
impossible thing to try and pull off
even nowadays I feel like that'd be hard
digging they could definitely make it
look better now but for 2003 to try to
get multiple agents mess and throw on
all the crazy matrix flying stunt work
they still had actors in there though
wasn't like they just computer-animated
it if you do the behind-the-scenes they
were still people doing the fights there
were still people a motion capture and
everything it's just the added digital
effects are not the greatest you know
back in 2003 when I first saw this you
know I think I remember being like I can
tell this is CG but I got it at the time
like it didn't ruin the movie for me at
the time and both times when I watched
it in the theaters people were clapping
throughout this fight and cheering
throughout the fight it was so cool for
its time so I don't know cuz like you
point out is still like an interestingly
choreographed fight yeah it's a cool
print idea of a fight you do you know
like multiple I think a lot of us were
willing to overlook the yeah for that
see American sniper with a fake baby I
never noticed it and didn't pull me out
of the movie are there any more scenes
than just this one I haven't actually
seen American sniper so this scene I
didn't think it was as bad but I thought
there was like an actual like birth room
scene or something no I don't know I
mean I feel like they would have showed
that because like even looking here the
baby I'm like if I wasn't really paying
attention it would I wouldn't have
noticed
cuz I was very pay much paying attention
when they were showing this clip and
when I was looking at it I wasn't
thinking like babies but you know it's
it's only a couple shots I don't think
it goes as far to turn this movie - it
almost unintentional comedy though I
think the Henry Cavill mustache is worse
than i disagree with number five the
goofy reunion return the king yeah it's
goofy it's cheesy cares at this point
let him have it for us it's such a
contrast to the rest of this entire
journey that yeah every time I've seen
it I'm just like yeah they're they're
they're overjoyed to be together they
just took home tarkness a good chunk of
each of their lives nearly dying and
going through terrible exams you know to
save the realm and a lot of them have
been separate from each other yes so now
they gonna reunite so not only is it
like I get to see you again but it's
like oh you're alive I think the actors
could have all done the same stuff it
might be because of the lighting it is
very light it's very such like you're
smoking up in heaven
Bane's death in the Dark Knight Rises
let's face it people there's a million
more reasons of how this movie could
have disappointed you beyond Bane's
death yeah I mean that's a that's a big
nail in the coffin for a lot of people
that's a crappy death it is it was a
very awful death deserves mom and like
henchman death for Bane say that the
only issue with TD care
although Breakfast at Tiffany's Man
Breakfast at Tiffany's was a film I I
greatly heavily enjoyed have you seen it
yeah that's not a couple years ago as
well I loved it it's one of those oldies
films that was super easy to sit back
and really enjoy it's got a weird
romantic tale about it but for the
Mickey Rooney Mickey Rooney oh god it's
so apparent that it's not a real
Japanese guy yeah part of me wishes I
could like plug into somebody from the
era's head to see how they would have
perceived it cuz yeah like the first
time I saw this and every time I've seen
these scenes since it's just it's so
awkward my first memory of this scene is
from dragging the Bruce Lee story when
Bruce Lee and Linda Lee are in the
theaters and they're watching this movie
oh and Bruce and they have to leave
because he's just so offended by it I
didn't understand why because I was a
little kid I was a real Japanese then I
watch this movie yeah it makes sense by
Bruce Lee what I don't even know aim at
Bruce Lee standing up standing up for
what's right it's not even funny like in
the slightest though that's the thing
it's it's lazy every there's a lot of
funny stuff in that movie but even that
is not witty whatsoever it's it's
terrible it's so cringe and then you're
just like you just want to cast Mickey
Rooney a Superman rewinding back time
has been a long it's like the main
criticism this movie gets I think that's
actually a really good thing to put on
this list I think this should be number
one if anything because this is a
classic movie and there's one specific
thing that happens at everyone
criticizes is cheesy and doesn't make
sense either yeah you would buy really
another you would more likely to screw
up you know the animals life cycles and
you know seasons and whatnot as far as
these dishonorable mentions
I don't know how problem to King Kong
skating around scene I actually don't
have a problem at all have you seen
Deathly Hallows Part 1 no I gotta see
the 6 7 and 7 2's for Harry Potter
you're so only redeeming thing about
that is that you've read the book but I
like this dance moment in it it's kind
of like melancholy I don't think it's
weird I joy the sunshine thing I like
what you said it's a whole act of a
different list yeah this is not a scene
because I'm part of the audience that
goes yeah I don't like this part of it
they say it here that it's captured well
it's captured like a Ridley Scott like
intense alien film
I don't thumb I Danny Boyle I think this
is the the element of the film that
causes me to not love the movie I know
you love the movie though yeah I do I do
like this movie a lot I get this is one
of those ones that people bring up a lot
when it comes to sunshine and I get why
it's jarring and why people don't like
it it is a bit jarring but I still enjoy
that sequence and I still think that
there's something to that sequence even
though it is such a left turn into
something altogether different than you
know the reality we've established for
the rest of the movie that's a fair
point Jay overall it's a good list I
like that this list is shorter than the
other WatchMojo like a 15 minute video
yeah that was enjoyable
I was really enjoyable anyway Andrew
thank you so much for recommending that
dog you guys can subscribe to
watchmojo.com you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell to get notified when our videos uh
that and check us on patreon full-length
TV show reactions weekly Q&A is a lot of
other good posts would love to and early
access to a lot of our uploads would
love to have you join us